Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational
嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，来帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程，我深受启发，这让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多思考。它也帮助我调整了心态，提醒我如果今年没能考上博士也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于它有多么鼓舞人心，
each and every person's journey was, and using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. Have you ever wondered what truly makes a great psychologist? Is it intelligence, years of training, or something else entirely? Today I am breaking down the essential skills and traits that every psychologist needs.
每个人的旅程都是如此，每天早上用这些故事来激励自己真是一种享受。我几乎舍不得读完它。你有没有想过，到底是什么造就了一位伟大的心理学家？是智力、多年的训练，还是其他完全不同的东西？今天，我将剖析每一位心理学家都需要具备的基本技能和特质。
And I'll even be role playing some real life examples. Yes, there's an outfit, which will really bring them to life. So if you're an aspiring psychologist or just fascinated by human behavior, stay tuned. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now the psychologist you see before you has taken many years to get to this point. I first went to do my undergraduate degree in psychology in 1999. Did all sorts
我甚至会进行一些现实生活中的角色扮演。没错，还有服装，这会让它们变得栩栩如生。所以，如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，或者只是对人类行为着迷，请继续关注。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，你面前的这位心理学家花了多年时间才走到这一步。我最初是在1999年攻读心理学本科学位。做了各种
of relevant experience, all sorts of different roles, did my doctorate in clinical psychology and I professionally qualified as a clinical psychologist in the year 2011. And along the way I've of course picked up traits that I think work pretty well for me in my career as a psychologist. So I thought it might be really interesting to have a look at what these are. This is especially helpful if you are considering a career in psychology or if you are already in it.
相关的经验，各种不同的角色，完成了临床心理学博士学位，并于2011年正式成为一名临床心理学家。在这一过程中，我当然也学到了一些我认为在心理学家职业生涯中非常有效的特质。所以我认为看看这些特质是什么会非常有趣。如果你正在考虑从事心理学职业，或者已经身处其中，这将特别有帮助。
So with no further ado, let's have a little look at the skills and traits that separate good psychologists from great ones. Whilst of course the qualifications and the knowledge are essential, I think it's actually the human skills, the way we listen, communicate to and respond to others that really define our impact and that of course are going to be the difference that makes the difference in this kind of battle with AI technologies. So the first traits that
所以，废话不多说，让我们来看看区分优秀心理学家和伟大心理学家的技能和特质。虽然学历和知识当然是必不可少的，但我认为真正定义我们影响力的其实是人文技能，即我们倾听、沟通和回应他人的方式，当然，这些也将是在与人工智能技术的这场博弈中产生差异的关键。所以，第一个特质，
I think are really important are those of empathy and emotional intelligence. Okay so let's define those terms. Empathy is the ability to understand and share the feelings of another person, whilst emotional intelligence is the skill of managing our own emotions and reading the emotions of others in order to be able to respond appropriately. Let's have a look at our first little role play example and if you're listening to this as an MP3 you are going to miss out on my costume so you may want to come and swing by to YouTube where I'm Dr Mary Ann Trent. Okay so let's have a look at our first role play example. A client has just shared that they're feeling overwhelmed with anxiety and that it feels
我认为非常重要的是同理心和情商。好吧，让我们定义一下这些术语。同理心是理解和分享他人感受的能力，而情商则是管理我们自己的情绪并解读他人情绪，以便能够做出适当反应的技能。让我们来看看我们的第一个小角色扮演示例，如果你是通过MP3收听，你可能会错过我的服装，所以你可能想去YouTube看看，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。好吧，让我们来看看我们的第一个角色扮演示例。一位来访者刚刚分享说他们感到焦虑不堪，并且感觉
like no one is understanding them. Here is maybe what not to do. Oh yeah. Hmm. Yeah. I used to, I used to be a bit like that really. Um, I think I was probably just, you know, overthinking it really. So have you tried not doing that?
好像没有人理解他们。这里也许是“不该做”的示范。哦，是啊。嗯。是啊。我以前，我以前也差不多是那样。嗯，我想我可能只是，你知道，想太多了。所以你试过不要那样吗？
Just you know, forget about it really and you've got to really remember that the people around you might find it a bit boring to keep kind of banging on about it. So maybe that's why they don't seem that interested. Have you tried that? Okay, so a better approach, which demonstrates the empathy and the emotional intelligence, which I think are so key,
就你知道，忘掉它吧，你真的得记住，你周围的人可能会觉得一直听你唠叨有点无聊。所以也许这就是他们看起来不太感兴趣的原因。你试过那样吗？好吧，那么一个更好的方法，展示了同理心和情商，我认为这是非常关键的，
would be something a bit like this. That sounds really tough. It makes complete sense that you'd feel really overwhelmed when you've got so much going on. You're not alone in this, and I want to help you to feel more in control. So I guess our takeaway from that is that a great psychologist doesn't immediately jump in and fix things. We're making space for emotions, we're making sure that our clients are feeling heard and validated and that they know that it's a safe
会是这样的。听起来真的很艰难。当你面临这么多事情时，感到不知所措是完全可以理解的。你并不孤单，我想帮助你感觉更有掌控力。所以我想我们从中得到的启示是，一位伟大的心理学家不会立即介入并解决问题。我们是在为情绪留出空间，我们确保我们的来访者感到被倾听和被认可，并且他们知道这是一个安全的
space that they can they can bring themselves and we can collaborate to find a way forwards. We're not sharing too much about ourselves and we're not making it all about ourselves either. We're not dismissing the client because if we do that you might find that that is the one and only time that you will see them. They won't come back. Okay so that's a little bit of food for thought. Let's think about the second of our traits, which I think are critical thinking and scientific rigor. Let's define our terms. So critical thinking means being able to analyse information,
空间，他们可以展现真实的自己，我们可以合作找到前进的方向。我们不会过多地分享关于我们自己的事情，也不会让一切都围绕着我们自己。我们不会打发来访者，因为如果我们那样做，你可能会发现那是你见到他们的唯一一次机会。他们不会再回来了。好吧，这算是一点思考。让我们来思考第二个特质，我认为是批判性思维和科学严谨性。让我们定义一下术语。所以批判性思维意味着能够分析信息，
evaluate research, and apply scientific evidence to practise. So what we think of as a scientist practitioner model. So an example of this might be that an influencer is sharing a kind of viral TikTok hack for how a 10 second social anxiety cure. I guess a great psychologist doesn't believe the hype. They would look at the evidence. They would look for what research shows us.
评估研究，并将科学证据应用于实践。也就是我们所说的科学家-实践者模型。这方面的一个例子可能是，一位网红正在分享一种病毒式的TikTok技巧，声称是10秒社交焦虑治愈法。我想一位伟大的心理学家不会相信这种炒作。他们会查看证据。他们会寻找研究向我们展示的内容。
They would look for what clients are telling us about this. They'd question its validity and assess whether it really works and whether it keeps on working, keeps on keeping those problems at bay. Because if it just comes back 10 times worse and bites that person in the bum that is not super helpful. We're not looking to distract from our problems, we're looking to make significant changes that help people to be able to cope and to function.
他们会寻找来访者告诉我们的关于这件事的信息。他们会质疑其有效性，并评估它是否真的有效，以及它是否能持续有效，能否持续地将这些问题拒之门外。因为如果它只是让问题以十倍的程度卷土重来，并让那个人吃尽苦头，那一点也不管用。我们不是为了分散对问题的注意力，我们是为了做出重大的改变，帮助人们能够应对并发挥功能。
So I guess our takeaway from that is yeah it's really nice to look at new ways of doing things and it can be helpful to explore with clients what they might have heard. But we do need to balance that curiosity with our scientific skepticism and to be able to protect our clients from misleading or harmful practices, we've got to be able to be using evidence-based principles
所以我认为我们从中得到的启示是，是的，看看新的做事方式确实很好，探索来访者可能听说过的内容也很有帮助。但我们需要将这种好奇心与我们的科学怀疑态度结合起来，为了保护我们的来访者免受误导性或有害做法的伤害，我们必须能够使用循证原则，
that really get results. Let's take a look at our third traits. And those are what I would think of as communication and education. Let's define our terms. So, of course, psychologists need to be able to translate complex psychological concepts into everyday language. And it's being able to do that to a variety of audiences and picking the right audience for that particular time. That might mean that it's for clients, for the public or even for
这些原则确实能带来结果。让我们来看看我们的第三个特质。那就是我所认为的沟通和教育。让我们定义一下术语。当然，心理学家需要能够将复杂的心理学概念转化为日常语言。并且能够针对不同的受众做到这一点，并为特定的时间选择合适的受众。这可能意味着它是针对来访者、公众，甚至是
other professionals. So let's have another look at a role play example. For example, a client might ask well what exactly is CBT? Cognitive behavioral therapy is a structured goal-oriented psychotherapy modality based on cognitive restructuring and behavior modification. Okay. So that didn't feel very dynamic or very human, did it? So what would be better? That's a great question. Thank you for bringing that to me. CBT is a type of therapy that looks at the way that our thoughts, our feelings and our
其他专业人士。所以让我们再看一个角色扮演示例。例如，一位来访者可能会问，CBT到底是什么？认知行为疗法是一种结构化的、以目标为导向的心理治疗模式，基于认知重构和行为矫正。好吧。这听起来不太生动，也不太人性化，对吧？那么什么会更好呢？这是一个很好的问题。谢谢你把它带给我。CBT是一种治疗方法，它着眼于我们的思想、我们的感受和我们的
behaviours all act together which might actually keep us stuck. It's kind of a way of helping us to really reprogram, stop doing things on autopilot, to help us think about how our brain and our body responds to challenges that arise for us. So our takeaway from that is that a great psychologist meets people where they are and makes psychology accessible and practical rather than intimidating. Okay, so this brings us on to our trait four,
行为如何共同作用，这实际上可能会让我们陷入困境。这是一种帮助我们真正重新编程的方法，停止在自动驾驶模式下做事，帮助我们思考我们的大脑和身体如何应对我们面临的挑战。所以我们从中得到的启示是，一位伟大的心理学家会站在来访者的角度，使心理学变得易于理解和实用，而不是令人望而生畏。好吧，这让我们进入第四个特质，
which is ethical integrity and professionalism. Let's define our terms. So psychologists must of course always act in the best interest of their clients. We've got to follow professional codes of ethics, maintain our boundaries and be aware of any biases we might have. An example might be that a client might ask to connect with you on social media or request personal advice outside of sessions. A great psychologist kindly but firmly maintains
即道德诚信和专业精神。让我们定义一下术语。所以心理学家当然必须始终以来访者的最大利益行事。我们必须遵守专业道德准则，保持我们的界限，并意识到我们可能存在的任何偏见。一个例子可能是，来访者可能会要求在社交媒体上与你联系，或在咨询之外寻求个人建议。一位伟大的心理学家会亲切但坚定地维护
those professional boundaries while still supporting the client's needs too. Trait 5. Flexibility and adaptability. Let's define our terms. Psychologists work with diverse individuals and ever-evolving research. This means that we must continually adapt our approach rather than relying on rigid methods. Let's have another little look at a role play. So in this one a client with social anxiety is struggling to engage with their traditional talking therapy. We need to stick with this approach for at least 12 weeks otherwise it's not gonna make a difference. Doesn't matter if it's not working right now, we need to stick with it. Okay so would you come back after
这些专业界限，同时仍然支持来访者的需求。特质5。灵活性和适应性。让我们定义一下术语。心理学家与多元化的个体和不断发展的研究一起工作。这意味着我们必须不断调整我们的方法，而不是依赖僵化的方法。让我们再看一个小角色扮演。在这个例子中，一位患有社交焦虑的来访者正在努力参与他们的传统谈话疗法。我们必须坚持这种方法至少12周，否则它不会产生任何影响。如果现在没用也没关系，我们需要坚持下去。好吧，那么在被告知这些之后，你会回来吗？
you had been told that? I don't think I would. So a better approach would be one that uses kind of adaptive thinking and really honours where the client is right now. It might look something like this. Thank you for raising that with me. I really want to make sure that we can help you to engage in this therapy as much as possible so that you get the benefits. It might be that you know small tweaks like the where we sit in the room might really help so rather than sitting one-on-one opposite each other we could perhaps think about sitting maybe shoulder to shoulder as we talk or maybe even doing some adult coloring both at the same time as we talk. Have you got
我不认为我会。所以一个更好的方法是使用那种适应性思维，并真正尊重来访者现在的状态。它可能看起来像这样。谢谢你向我提出这一点。我真的想确保我们能帮助你尽可能多地参与到这种治疗中，这样你就能获得益处。也许你知道，一些小的调整，比如我们在房间里的坐姿，可能会有很大帮助，所以与其面对面坐着，我们也许可以考虑在交谈时并排坐着，或者甚至在交谈的同时一起做一些成人填色。你有什么
any other ideas or suggestions for things that you think might be helpful? So I think in this second example a great psychologist is really knowing that one size does not fit all and that we need to be able to adapt our approach to fit the person in front of us and to make sure that the client feels that they've got some buy-in, they've got some power to be able to really kind of work collaboratively rather than just being done to. So those are my five key traits that make a great psychologist. We've covered empathy, critical thinking, clear communication,
其他想法或建议吗？所以我认为在第二个例子中，一位伟大的心理学家真正知道没有一种方法适合所有人，我们需要能够调整我们的方法以适应面前的人，并确保来访者感到他们有参与感，他们有能力真正地进行协作，而不是仅仅被动地接受治疗。所以这就是我认为造就一位伟大心理学家的五个关键特质。我们涵盖了同理心、批判性思维、清晰的沟通、
ethical integrity and adaptability. But what do you think? Which one of these traits do you think is most important and are there any other skills that you would add to the list? Please do drop a comment below and if you found this content helpful, please don't forget to like and subscribe. To learn other great ways of being a brilliant reflective psychologist, please do check out the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, which gets wonderful reviews. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I'll see you very soon. Take care. Hi, I'm Max, and I work as an assistant psychologist in the learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind
道德诚信和适应性。但你怎么看？你认为这些特质中哪一个最重要？还有什么其他技能你会添加到列表中吗？请在下方发表评论，如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，请别忘了点赞和订阅。要了解成为一名出色的反思型心理学家的其他好方法，请查看《临床心理学家合集》这本书，它获得了极好的评价。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快再见。保重。嗨，我是马克斯，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但肯定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考上临床博士。考虑到这个最终目标，
I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marian's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills such as compassion and empathy you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more
我想看看外面有什么，看看哪些书对这方面有帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家合集》，并决定这对我的旅程来说是一个很好的购买。我发现玛丽安的书非常翔实，非常有见地。我特别喜欢这些故事如何让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你拥有良好的社交技能，如同情心和同理心，你就能做到。我会强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家推荐这本书，也向那些想多了解一点
about the world of clinical psychology, and maybe want to work in that field one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于临床心理学世界，并且也许有一天想在该领域工作的人推荐。此集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。